Transcriber: Radwa samy
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
مساء الخيرات جميعًا،
هل تشعرون بالبرد مثلي أم لا؟
إن شاء الله وبإذن الله
يعطيكم كلامي قليلًا من الدفء.
شكرًا جزيلًا أستاذ عبد الحكيم على المقدمة.
الجليس الدائم.
كم شخص منكم يحبُ تغيير حياته؟
لا تعجبه الحياة التي يعيشها،
ويريد تغييرها تغييرًا جذريًا،
أو يحسنها قليلًا سواء لاقَ دعمًا
من الناس الذين حوله أم لا.
إذَا، ليس هناك أحد، حسنًا!
استمعوا إلى هذا السؤال التالي،
كم واحد منكم عنده شغف لشيء معين
يحب ممارسته مثل الرسم أو الرياضة،
ولضيق الوقت أو لكثرة المشاغل،
لم يعد باستطاعته القيام بها،
فقد شغفه.
إذا كان أحدكم من هؤلاء الأشخاص، ارفع يدك.
أنا كذلك كنت واحدة من هذا القبيل.
لكن بداية،
سأتكلم عن “ذا سوزي” وهو اسم مدونتي،
من الواضح أنها تتمحور عن الكتب، أليس كذلك؟
سأتكلم في البداية عن بذرة الشغف.
بدأت حكايتي منذ الصغر،
وشغفي في قراءة الكتب،
لأن والدي، رحمه الله،
كان لديه مكتبة تجارية.
وكانت الكتب والقصص متاحة لي ولإخواني.
فكنا نأخذ منها الكتب والقصص،
أيضًا أختي الكبيرة فاطمة، حفظها الله،
كانت توفر لي ولأخي نايف،
القصص المسموعة التي يرافقها نص مكتوب.
كنا نستمتع ونحن نسمعها لدرجة
أننا حفظناها غيبًا.
في فترة أو في مرحلة المراهقة،
حدثث لي قصة جعلت شغفي بالقراءة يزداد،
في يوم من الأيام،
طلبتُ من أختي فاطمة أن أتحدث معها
وأخبرتها أن لا أحد يفهمني
وأحسُ أنني غير محبوبة،
وكنت أبكي.
فاحتضنتني وقالت لي،
أولًا، أنت محبوبة من الجميع.
ثانيًا، المشاعر التي تمرين بها الآن
هي مشاعر طبيعية نتيجة لمرحلة المراهقة.
هل تعرفين ما الذي تحتاجين إليه؟
أنت تحتاجين إلى أن يكون لك صديق،
و لن تجدي صديقًا أفضل من الكتاب.
كانت تمتلك أختي فاطمة
مكتبة كبيرة جدًا فيها جميع أنواع الكتب.
فيها كتب؛
في الأدب وفي الفلسفة
وفي السياسة وفي الشعر.
وكانت هذه الكتب مقدسة جدًا بالنسبة إليها.
بالرغم من ذلك، أعطتني مطلق الحرية
في اختيار أي كتاب أريده وأقرأه،
شرط أن أعيده لها بعد أن أنتهي من قراءته.
في الحقيقة، في تلك الفترة، جذبتني
كتب غازي القصيبي، رحمه الله،
وكذلك كتب أنيس منصور ودواوين شعر
نزار قباني  وكتب مصطفى محمود.
أذكر أنه في تلك الفترة،
أنني سافرت من خلال الكتب مع أنيس منصور
حول العالم في مئتي يوم.
وقطفت مئة وردة ورق  مع غازي القصيبي.
وأتذكر أيضًا أني استمعت
إلى اعترافات العشاق
مع مصطفى محمود.
وكذلك حلّقت في دواوين شعر نزار قباني.
ثم حدث ما لم يكن بالحسبان،
فقدت الشغف للقراءة،
خاصة خلال العشر سنوات والنصف التي كنت أدرس
فيها مرحلتي الماجستير والدكتوراة
أثناء بعثتي إلى الولايات
المتحدة الأمريكية.
بطبيعة الحال كنت أقرأ كتبًا علمية،
ولكن صدقًا وحقًا ما كنت أمسك كتابًا
لكي أقرأه لمجرد القراءة.
لم أكن أجد نفسي في هذا الأمر،
في كل مرة كنت أزور فيها الوطن،
كنت أخبر أختي فاطمة
عن هذه المشكلة وأشتكي لها،
فكانت تحاول تشجيعي إما أن تمدح لي
كتابًا معينًا أو تنصحني به،
أو تعطيني واحدًا من الكتب
التي أحب مؤلفيها أو كتّابها.
بصراحة، كنت بمجرد أن أقرأ صفحة واحدة
أغلق الكتاب وأعيده لها من جديد،
لم يكن شغفي موجودًا أبدًا
للقراءة في ذلك الوقت.
ولكن، قبل أربع سنوات،
قرأت رواية العصفورية لغازي القصيبي.
أتذكر حينها كيف كنت أضحك وأبكي
مع ذاك البروفيسور المجنون.
أحسست حينها أن غازي القصيبي أحيى،
وأشعل جذوة الشغف
في داخلي من جديد للقراءة.
فبدأت من وقت لأخر،
أقرأ كتابًا هنا وكتابًا هناك،
لكن ليس باستمرار.
في بداية 2020،
قررت أن أتحدى نفسي،
وكان هدفي أن أستعيد شغفي مجددًا،
وأن يكون بشكل مستمر.
فتحديت نفسي وليس أي أحد آخر،
ولم أدخل في مسابقة
لأن هدفي كان شخصيًا.
وقررت قراءة سبعين كتابًا خلال سنة واحدة.
قرأت مرة،
إذا كنت تحبُ تحقيق هدفًا معينًا يخصك،
عليك أن تضعه أمام عينيك،
يعني أن تكتبه.
كما لابد لك أن تخصص وقتًا معينًا لتحقيقة،
أو أن تحدد له فترة معينة،
وهذا ما قمتُ به حيث حددتُ رقمًا
وهو سبعين كتابًا وحددت سنة.
وأن تشاركه مع الآخرين.
وقررت في هذه المرة أن أعلن
عن هذا الأمر وعن هذا الهدف،
وأن ألتزم بالتدوين عن كل كتاب أقرأه،
في مدونتي .
ومن هنا بدأت قصة مدونتي “ذا سوزي“.
(تصفيق)
بالنسبة للقراءة، ليس هذا الشيء
غريبًا بالنسبة لي.
بالنسبة للكتابة،
فقد كنت من وقت لآخر،
أكتب بعض الخواطر أو بعض المذكرات.
بالنسبة للتصوير، فهوايتي متواضعة جدًا.
في هذه المرة وأثناء التحدي،
قررتُ الالتزام، كما قلت، بالقراءة،
سبعون كتاب خلال سنة
يعني تقريبًا خمسة كتب، آسفة،
يعني كتاب كل خمسة أيام تقريبًا.
وأن أدون عنه،
وأن أصنع كذلك صورة تحمل هذا الكتاب،
وبعض القطع التي اختارها لتمثل
أو تعني لي شيئًا يتعلق بهذا الكتاب،
أو رحلتي مع هذا الكتاب.
لماذا سبعون وليس خمسون وليس مئة؟
لأني أحب رقم سبعة بكل بساطة.
الأمر الثاني، هل كان ورقيًا
أو إليكترونيًا أو سمعيًا؟
فالحقيقة أن الناس مختلفون؛ هناك من يحب
قراءة كتب إلكترونية وهناك من يحب سماعها
وبالنسبة لي أحب الكتب الورقية.
أحب احتضان الكتاب بين يدي .
والأمر الثالث، اختياراتي للكتب،
على أي أساس ستكون اختياراتي للكتب.
لم يكن هناك منهجية معينة لهذا الأمر،
إما أن أختار كتابًا أو أحد ينصحني بكتاب،
أو أن يحملني كتاب  إلى كتاب آخر .
أي في ذات مرة قرأت كتابًا
كان يتكلم عن الجاهظ.
بعد أن أنهيته، قرأت كتاب البخلاء للجاهظ.
هذه كانت،
مبادرتي “سبعون كتابًا في سنة”.
وكان هذا أول كتاب في التحدي
في الرابع من كانون الثاني/يناير عام 2020.
طبعًا، الصورة التي أخذتها بسيطة جدًا.
(تصفيق)
ولكن بالنسبة لي كان الأمر صعبًا قليلًا.
لأنه خلف الكواليس كان لدي أبطال.
لديهم شغف وفضول
يعرفون ماذا تفعل هذه البنت.
“باشن” الذي علي اليمين، قطي،
“شغف” و“بونيتا” يعني حلوة
باللغة الإسبانية، على اليسار.
كان لديهم اهتمام ماذا تفعل هذه؟
ختمت هذه المبادرة،
في 21 شهر آب/أغسطس عام 2020 .
يعني قبل انتهاء العام بأربعة شهور .
أنهيت الكتاب رقم سبعين في هذا التحدي.
(تصفيق)
هل سأتوقف؟  بالطبع لا، لن أتوقف.
فأكملت لأن الأمر أصبح فعلًا
عادة يومية، خصلة يومية.
كنت ألتزم بقراءة هذه الكتب
سواء أعجبتني أو لم تعجبني.
أسمعتم من يقول لكم
أن الدواء يشفي وإن كان علقمًا؟
وكان شفائي أن أستعيد شغف القراءة مجددًا.
يقول العقاد:
“القراءة وحدها هي التي تعطي الإنسان الواحد
أكثر من حياة واحدة،
لأنها تزيد هذه الحياة عمقًا،
وإن كانت لا تطيلها بمقدار الحساب“.
من خلال الكتب التي قرأتها،
ازدادت حياتي عمقًا وفهمًا ومعرفة.
ولذلك،
تم استعادة الشغف
وأنهيت مئة كتاب خلال سنة 2020.
(تصفيق)
لم يحدث في يوم واحد أن توقفت عن القراءة.
ليس بالضرورة أن يكون شغفكم القراءة،
ولكن فكروا في أي شغف أو أي أمر
أنتم تحبو، أن تفعلوه
و استعيدوا شغفكم به،
لممارستة والاستمتاع به،
وابدأوا تحدي مع أنفسكم.
ويبقَ الكتاب خير جليسي في كل زمان
ليس فقط جليس، نكرة،
ولكن هو معرفة.
جليسي أنا سوزان في كل مكان وفي كل زمان.
شكرًا لكم!
(تصفيق)
ختامًا أحب أن أشكر عائلتي الجميلة،
البيئة المحفزة منذ الصغر،
لهذا الشغف .
أحب أيضًا أن أشكر كل أصدقائي وصديقاتي .
وكل الأشخاص الذين دعموني وتابعوني
خلال فترة التحدي.
ورسالتي لكم أنتم،
اختر كتابًا واقرأه وأبحر
من خلاله وعبر عن اختيارك .
شكرًا لكم!
(تصفيق)